hello everyone and welcome to a really
wild game from the Abu Dhabi blitz
challenge organized by Abu Dhabi chess
club on chess calm it's Daniel Du Bois
with the white East against Neha serene
again from the semifinals of the event
first it was a qualifier and then if
you've won the qualifier you went into
the knockout phase of the tournament so
really exciting game I just thought
contact me on Twitter saying that it
would make for a nice video and well
after seeing the game I do have to agree
so without further ado let's check it
out dubov opens with E for now we have
c6 studying goes for the caro-kann
defense with d4 d5 and now II five going
for the advanced variation which can be
tricky for black so instead of going for
some normal stuff with Bishop to a5 we
have c6 which is a very popular by black
avoiding this tricky area and if white
go c3 then after East six for example we
just transposed into the French where
black is down a tempo but instead of e6
black could go for some knife the c6
action and probably get a position where
white might be uncomfortable in or maybe
not a really familiar with so instead
just the D captures on c5 grabbing the
phone abandoning the center with East
six by Serena opening up the bishops
diagonal to recapture on c5 n Knight to
f3
dubov just continues development we have
Bishop captures on c5 and now Bishop to
d3 Knight to c6 and we have castles here
Knight the G to e7 the knight will now
come to g6 probably to put more pressure
on the e5 pawn and night beat the b2
we have nice - g6 now putting more
pressure on the pawn here and the knight
the b3 there before defending the pawn
first attacking the bishop on c5 there
should be six and rook to e1 now d5
point is nicely defended with castles by
serene and now there are some games were
c3 and also better of the e3 were played
but here we have Queen to e2 adding even
more protection to the pawn kind of over
protecting it
which would be proud and it is as of
move 11 that we have a completely new
game so here we have f6 by black
challenging that whites central pawn
which is basically a bone-in blacks
throat and it is one of the one of the
positions where it's okay to play f6
usually when you play the fringe order
or the caro-kann you will challenge the
advanced e5 pawn with f6
so e captures on f6 we have Queen
captures on f6 and now you don't want to
allow black to start pushing for example
the e pawn so Bishop to g5 attacking the
Queen allowing Queen captures on b2
which serene gladly does he accepts the
pawn rook a b1 and now Queen to c3
Buster back to d2 we have Queen back the
f6 and here double repeats better back
to g5 probably checking if if serine is
interested in repeating even more and
here he just goes back Queen to f7 he go
he could go for a counter with Knight to
f4 which would attack White Queen but he
prefers Queen to f7 and now what's
what's the the compensation behind
behind above sacrifice well he does have
the semi open file for the rope which
for the moment isn't all that much but
okay
he goes for C four challenges black
strong center of course not not captures
first h6
attacking the bishop the shabak the e3
now challenging black's bishop and now
Knight to f4 saying that okay if you
don't want to allow my knight to have
this beautiful outpost you have to give
up your bishop pair which is what dubov
does so Bishop captures we have Queen
captures on f4 and now rook beat d1
abandons the semi open B file and the
Bishop to d7
I just continuing development connecting
rooks the other group can now also enter
the game and now as there are some holes
here on the light squares the brush of
the b1 a usual plan you want to shift
your Queen over to d3 or c2 and create
some threats along the h7 square so look
the f6 preparing g6 so the rook will be
defending the Ponte cut off this
diagonal we have Queen to c2 now hoping
to infiltrate would quint h7 check about
the G
6.now and okay it the defense but for
the moment this rook is stuck here
guarding the pawn see capture son d5 we
have a capture son d5 and now rook
captures on d5 grabbing that pawn which
could be tricky as it allows Knights the
b4 with a fork on the Queen and the rook
but Queen to d1 and here Serena has to
decide whether he wants to grab the rook
or not it's it's okay to capture the
rook if you capture the rook then Queen
captures with chick comes with a double
attack on the bishop and you could go
Bishop to e6 but then just route
captures it so you would have to block
with rook to f7 and it looks a bit fishy
but in the end after something like rope
to f8 and the use of the bishop over
here you will have two beautiful bishops
slicing over to the tiller Kings king's
castle should be good for black but
serene is not interested in any greedy
decision so first he just goes Bishop to
c6 he first puts his bishops in optimal
squares and now you should probably go
for someone like rook to be to bring the
route back and then play this endgame
captures captures and then we will just
have a lot of characters here where
White's pawn structure is a bit is a bit
ruined but all in all shouldn't be all
that much better for black however Du
Bois Vieux decided to go for Queen rook
to e4 first and we reach the position
that basically starts starts our game so
now you don't really want to move the
Queen what you want to do is give up the
Queen and this is exactly what neat hell
did he decided for Knight captures on d5
just a queen for two rooks and he will
be left with these two beautiful bishops
and when the arrow comes into the game
it should be a very nice attack with
rook captures on f4 Knight ers on a4
and now Nightbeat to d4 hoping to
eliminate at least one of the bishops
but now rook the d8 attacking the knight
here now twice we have Queen to b3 check
on pinning and Bishop to d5 now just
challenging the Queen Queen a4 and now
comes King to g7 just
getting the King to a little bit of a
safer Square
however rook the c8 here was extremely
deadly threatening rook to c1 check and
after the better blocks it now you can
go look to see for add another attacker
here to the to the night and they were
just win material for black so it was in
the position but okay King to g7 and the
now comes h4 just creating some
breathing room for the King also hoping
to challenge blacks defenses here but
now Knight captures and g2 by setting
very exciting stuff because if King
captures then you can just capture on d4
Bishop captures here and the Queen is
unable to capture because if Bishop
captures then again you also lose the
Queen
so Queen to b4 now with ideas of maybe
trying to infiltrate the position with
Queen to e7 so look the d7 defending it
and now comes the Knights thief I've
going after that rook on d7 so rook the
c7 and now comes Bishop captures and g6
and again we have this well one of the
critical moments in the game where you
have to decide what to do here problem
is if you play rook captures and g6 try
and give up the route for two pieces
first you get Knight f5 trick and only
after King f6 Knight captures here King
captures here and now Knights the e7
check with the idea of winning the
bishop so we remove the King and allow
this capture here or you capture here
and you get to this position either for
its Queen against against the three
pieces all in all if anyone's better
kind of should be black but with the
King so wide open and on the board would
be hard for for black to create some
some counter chances so what an eagle
did instead here is Knight to f4 he just
decided to attack the bishop here which
isn't the the correct way to go the
creative way to go is Knight to h4 with
this is the same idea the only
differences the knight also covers the
f5 square and that's really important
here however we have Knight to f4 now
with a double attack on the bishop but
now comes Knight to f5 with check and
now if you just move the king then Queen
captures on f4 and the white is just
better so here sameen has to give up the
rook we have rush of characters on f5
and
work the ce-1 check and now the king
hunt begins king h2 we have worked the
h1 width check King g3 we have night
study - with check the bishop covers f3
Knight f4 so the King has to go up the
board all of these squares are not
available to the white king so King g4
only move and now comes work the g1 with
check seven continues checking the the
King even though bishop the d8 was a bit
more precise here you just want to
capture that pawn on h4 and then it
would be extremely hard for white to get
out of this it is possible to defend but
it's hard to say if in such a good game
you would be able to find it the only
option is Knight to g6 blocking this and
now you go rook the g1 checking is 3 and
now it's basically a draw by repetition
check check check check check
if you go to h5 Bishop f3 just the winds
for black so like I said the shop d8 was
a little bit better but okay Ruby g1
check we have King to h5 and now you
kinda need to get this Knight to f4 if
the night lands on f4 with check that's
mate the rook cuts off the entire G file
away from the White King so you want to
get Knight to f4 in but how do you do it
measure up the c5 by serine trying to
get of course characters and Knight to
f4 would mate but do both doesn't of
course oblige he goes back Quinta Quinta
a for Queen to d2 was a little bit
better but for the following reasons
here do both played Quinte for but now
of course you are welcome to pause the
video and win the game for 4/7 while I
give you a couple of seconds so as the
plan and the previous move was kicked
the Queen away from the fourth-ranked
that's why Bishop to c5 was played so
here congratulations to everyone who
found b5 it's another move that kicks
the Queen away from the fourth rank and
here you can see that all of the squares
are taken away from the White Queen the
night covers f4 so basically if you
don't want to suffer mate or lose the
Queen for nothing you have to play
something like this and then characters
captures and just Bishop capture
something - for example leave you with
owning endgame where black is just up a
piece but instead
this b5 move serene played King to f6
with a double attack on the bishop and
Knight which is weird because serene
played Bishop to c5 with with the sole
purpose of picking the Queen away from
the fourth rank to be able to deliver
Knight to a4 checkmate and then he
misses b5 which is which is really weird
as it's the same idea you just try to
kick the Queen away from that and there
are no there are no tricks here after a
pawn to b5 there's no Queen here check
there's no Queen here check a bishop
covers that so it is really weird that
he missed that but okay King f6 he
probably thought that this was just as
winning and now comes Knight to d7 with
check here white makes a suboptimal move
but it's okay it's it's a blitz game
well even though I think it's a blitz
game I'm not really sure but I think it
is Knight to d7 with check and now comes
King captures on f5 which again is not
the the most precise way but I I do
imagine it's a blues game so we're not
going to over analyze it however a king
to g7 is just it's just much better
again you will not be able to capture
here because now Queen if Bishop f7
check bushel blocks and Bishop captures
here is made any check to the White King
is made because the rook is cutting the
King off from escaping to the G file but
studying played King captures an f5 and
now well now he's in a lot of trouble
because of Queen to c2 check and he will
not be able to deliver any checks this
will not be happening this will not be
happening because well after King f4 we
have Queen d2 check King f3 and now
Queen captures a bishop with check King
captures on f2 and now Queen captures on
c5 with check and now Knight to f4
I will not be all that tailed all that
impressive because well King can just
capture here so king f1 and now comes
King captures on age sex and the white
king escapes from any mating ideas we
have Knight to f4 but now just Queen to
a5 do both pins the night we have rock
to g6 with track but now dubov is not
even interested in escaping with the
King he just gives up the Queen and says
okay
is now a winning and game studying
captured and we have King captors and g6
and it was in this position that nihill
serena resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here but what
what a game it was so many chances and i
don't believe that he missed b5 as it's
it's not something that you have to see
especially since on the previous move he
played the exact same idea
sorry i'm unable to reach the position
very very quickly but yeah here he
played Bishop to c5 with the exact idea
of getting the Queen away from the
defense of the fourth rank and then
after this he doesn't play b5 extremely
weird I don't know what happened here
but you know it's just anything can
happen and everything will happen and
such is the case here another ruined
immortal but definitely an exciting game
and I'm very happy that I was able to
show it sure that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to think I'd
immediately often again then alexandre
bolduc jonathan cook Robert Vasquez and
the Christopher Drake for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga the LI watches 0 vs top fish saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and wherever whatever else
happens in the chess world we are
starting our elite chess Fridays
tomorrow so hope you are ready for that
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here I'm thankful for watching
and I will see you soon
with everything I already mentioned so
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day